Connor you first predicted this fight
two years ago on my show let's take a
look what if you were in the ring with
Floyd Mayweather what do you think would
happen he's obviously an incredibly one
of the greatest boxers anyone's ever
seen if you're asking what I like to
fight Floyd I mean who would not like to
dance around the ring for 100 million if
we were to get it on I would most gently
dismantle him also Connor are you
sticking with that prediction are you
going to dismantle Floyd Mayweather now
that it's a reality there will be no
dancing in their cone and I'm gonna go
straight forward and put him away inside
four rounds inside four rounds okay well
this is interesting because Floyd's been
talking Floyd says that he is going to
go to you now he is famously a counter
puncher the defensive fighter doesn't
really go towards other fighters do you
think he's playing mind games who to
think he might really try and step in
there and trade blows with you he's
saying he's gonna come towards me I'm
saying I'm gonna come towards him we're
gonna find out pretty early he was
telling the truth so we'll see who takes
a back step for excited for the contest
I will go forward for him and put him
away Floyd has another quote he said
this about you he says you have two
options you're going down on your face
or your back you would care to first of
all I would prefer bow down in the
history books telling that's me we go to
some I am down in the history books I'm
going down to the history books
I will dominated the UFC and I will
dominate boxing also it has never before
been done so that's where I'm going down
in the history books
Floyd has also said that you've never
had to fight for this long he says you
can't go the distance how do you prepare
for going 12 rounds you've got to go
probably a lot longer are you training
any differently yeah we've made slight
adjustments in my cardio preparation
it's actually been very enjoyable to go
from five five-minute rounds which is
what we are used to which is 25 minutes
to 12 treatment at rounds of boxing
which is 26 minutes slight adjustments
but we are more than ready I don't 12
rounds last night I've done multiple 12
round fights in the gym in the lead up
to this we are more than ready Floyd is
praying for me to fatigue in there but I
will not fatigue I will continue to
press forward and I will break him at 40
years of age he will not sustain my pace
so that is it
[Applause]
you